so Saturday we're shooting this scene
for the movie and we invited everyone
down to Bryan Park to come shoot with us
you know any listeners who want to come
down we had a real nice turnout and
people were just really into the movie
and having fun there's a scene in the
movie that called for a band you know so
when I was when we were first talking
about I said my fantasy would be to have
AC DC do this scene but of course
yeah how do we get AC DC to do anything
you know what I mean because those guys
you know yeah so anyway we're doing this
scene I don't want to give away the
scene too much but I take to the stage
and we're all up there and everything
and
and then all of a sudden I introduce AC
DC well the crowd out there had no idea
and on Friday when I said to everyone
come on down
I didn't I couldn't go on the interstate
ACDC she's going to be there because
they wouldn't the park commission
wouldn't let us shoot if I announced
that you know we were all going to be
there together because they were afraid
that it would be like 100 000 people to
show up and they'll have a real problem
on their hands right that's right Demi
sir yeah so uh all of a sudden AC DC
comes out and then all of a sudden you
hear like this familiar riff it was like
uh and the crowd is going nuts
and I'm just sitting I'm standing there
rocking you know just my mind is blown
I love having you guys in the movie it's
just such a isn't it a cool moment there
was a lot going on there you know it was
it was almost live you know that you
know the start when you're shooting with
them when the whole crowd comes in at
the end it felt real it was good you
know it was real good and you know what
was weird too like uh all of a sudden
one of the takes you guys blew up smoke
bombs on the stage and almost got you it
almost nailed me yeah you almost got it
you know I'm not saying I'm a dozy
booger but I am at that time in the
morning and when the producer guy or the
guy said whatever you do keep away from
this part of the Stitch because it's
going to be big smog bombs growing up
and it's gonna explode on you yeah yeah
you know straight in one of the audio
though right and I get on the stage and
you went right next to this and I just
disappeared in this big coat
oh I just went out yeah the man wasn't
used in movies you got it like you get
in the middle of a song and all of a
sudden they stop you right I that was
weird wasn't it I put you off a bit like
yes but did you see what happened and
one of the ticks when they said and Gua
and a guy didn't roll a tip but I'm just
out of habit just started playing right
and did you know that happened no what
happened he played live once because the
tape wasn't on yeah I know and so they
just started playing and nobody ever
knew that that wasn't on the tape right
now that's pretty cool but and now and
the women's Coach again I can't have
this you know yeah I need control
Betty I like when Betty has the yellow
day crowd and yell at the band I can't
have this I it's just you know come on
work with me people I felt bad for Buddy
she said well you know why don't you go
over and I'll tell you what to say to
the band you talk to them because you
can interpret what they're saying for me
I guess it's like she goes over and goes
okay I went over to Angus all right
Chris I tried talking to you I go Brian
when the band comes out how are you
going to Stage this thing and he goes
and then Betty's standing there and goes
what did he say so it goes
smoking a cigarette he's getting all
wasted I gotta be honest with you buddy
I know Brian but I don't know I don't
know so let me go over and ask Angus
because maybe he's sort of like the guy
you know who does the staging and
everything because Brian's the lead
singer and he's just a little messed up
so I go over to Angus and I say Angus
look
you're the guy tell me what's gonna
happen here when you guys come out how
do you want to Stage IT you want to come
up from the left if I come up and walk
around to the right should I shake your
hand here he goes
brains ain't me Forte
and walks away
and then like with the nobody can deal
with anybody
in bed so I just said to Betty look I'm
not going to sit here and try to
interpret this man they're gonna just
come out and do whatever they want have
57 billion cameras yeah you know Betty's
got that good looking at first when
you're talking about this this lesson
producer Lassie because I was talking a
while you know that sort of silly smell
where you it looks like they've got wind
yeah that glazed looks it just goes yeah
what looked like you had to pass gas it
looked like it's a hard wind but what it
was was a puzzled look oh there's
another Corker
she was puzzled I mean everyone was well
we I did a scene there's another scene
with a bunch of rock stars in this movie
and uh you know I work with the Slash
from Guns and Roses and stuff and Betty
was trying to direct them ending up yeah
well yeah yeah almost standing up so I
in Ozzy Osbourne you know yeah so I uh I
walk over to those guys and I bet he
said to me you better you just better go
tell I'll tell you what to tell them to
do but you better go talk to them
because I don't think they're even
paying attention I don't know what's
going on
yeah
foreign